Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, bleiben wir jetzt eigentlich bei Twitter oder gehen wir zu Threads?
Ich würde sagen kommt drauf an wer den Käfigkampf gewinnt.
Musik Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 464 vom siebten Juli 2023 eurem Fight Club
für digitale Rechte und schlechten Humor,
besonderen Humor wollte ich sagen, also speziellen Humor sagt man dann glaube
ich, den haben wir nämlich hier, glauben wir hier zu haben im Angebot und ihr
entscheidet, wie das ausgeht jedes mal.
Ich fände das so schön, also ich meine, die werden diesen Käfigkampf nicht machen,
aber es kann nur Gewinner geben, es kann nur Gewinner geben,
wenn Elon Musk und Mark Zuckerberg in einen Käfigkampf sich begeben.
Irgendwie war das, also ich glaube, Musk hatte irgendwie rumgescherzt darüber,
dass Facebook einen Twitter-Konkurrenten bauen würde.
Dann hat irgendein, so ein Twitter-Ei nennt man die, glaub ich,
so ein Account mit nicht vielen Followern, gesagt, ja, ich finde,
ihr solltet einen Käfigkampf machen.
Und dann hat Musk geantwortet, ja, finde ich auch, ich bin bereit.
Und dann hat irgendwie Zuckerberg geantwortet, ich weiß nicht,
ob der twittert oder ob der twittern lässt oder wie auch immer, ja, wann und wo.
Und was halt vielleicht nicht allen bekannt ist, ist, dass der Musk jetzt in
den letzten Jahren irgendwie Jiu-Jitsu trainiert hat, was für einen Käfigkampf
nicht das schlechteste Training ist.
Also Jujitsu hat irgendwie als Ziel, den Gegner so schnell wie möglich kampfunfähig zu machen.
Der Musk hat das gemacht, ich dachte der Zuckerberg.
Ja der Zuckerberg hat, hab ich Musk gesagt?
Ja du hast Musk gesagt.
Nee Quatsch der hat auf dem Sofa gesessen und getwittert, der war ja so ganz
schön aufgegangen, der muss mal ein bisschen auf sich achten.
Und das hat der Mark Zuckerberg halt gemacht.
Und ich glaube, das wäre ein relativ kurzer Prozess, der dann wahrscheinlich
mit irgendeinem Riesengeschrei von Musk einhergehen würde, dass der Zuckerberg
sich nicht an die Regeln gehalten hat oder so.
Aber das Schöne an so einem Käfigmatch ist ja, da kommst du so schnell nicht raus.
Und ich würde oben auch zumachen dann. Und das wäre einfach zu schön.
Twitter hat ja jetzt angekündigt, dass sie Facebook verklagen wollen.
Ich sag immer Facebook, nicht Meta.
Weil sie angeblich irgendwelche Ex-Twitter-Employees beschäftigt hätten,
um sozusagen ihre Maschine schnell zu kriegen, als ob Facebook keine Erfahrung
mit Skalierung hätte, aber die haben gar keine Twitter-Employees.
Und zweitens, nachdem du eine Firma mit 10.000 oder 11.000 Mitarbeitern übernimmst und 7.000, 8.000,
Leute und Ligma und Johnson und alle da rauskircherst, dann irgendjemand anders
zu verklagen, dass er die eingestellt hat, dafür gehörst du auch in den Käfig.
Mit auf die Fresse von rechts und links.
Schade, dass uns das nicht vergönnt sein wird.
Aber wenn, dann sag ich dir das wird das Jahrhundertereignis,
das wird wie Mondlandung,
das wird wie Barcelona gegen Madrid,
das wird wie der letzte Kampf von Henry Maske oder wetten das oder sowas,
das wird so ein richtiger Straßenfeger, da machen die alle zu.
Oder LNP 500. LNP 500, Camp, CCC Camp oder so,
also es wird so ein Event, ja, oder auch nicht, ich meine so wie die drauf sind,
das ist das Pay TV Event, daran stolzen die sich alle gesund.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Wrestling, das ist dann alles vorher so abgekartet.
Das ist einfach vorher klar, dass der Musk irgendwie rechts-links kriecht und
dann bricht der Zuckerberg dem den Arm.
Deine Hoffnung. Ich weiß nicht, also.
Oder der Musk tritt dem unvermittelt vor der ersten Glocke einfach direkt in die Eier.
Das könnte auch sein. Aber so oder so, es wird auf jeden Fall nicht langweilig.
Ich glaube es wird kurz und es kann auch nur Gewinner geben. Ist ja völlig egal.
Naja, wird eh nicht stattfinden, schade.
Jaja, auf jeden Fall hat jetzt jeder von diesen Möchtegerns,
hat jetzt irgendwie so eine Textnachrichtenplattform, die eine funktioniert
nicht mehr so richtig, die andere funktioniert noch nicht so richtig und das
wird bestimmt total spannend.
Und deswegen hauen die sich jetzt aufs Maul.
Aber Musk kriegt auf jeden Fall jetzt schon mal einen Trostpreis für sein Lebenswerk,
weil also 44 Milliarden US-Dollar auszugeben, dann sozusagen den real eingeschätzten
Wert davon dieses Unternehmens dann mal so innerhalb von ein paar Monaten zu halbieren,
das alles dann noch schlechter funktionieren zu lassen als vorher,
sich bei allen Werbepartnern zu versauen und dann parallel auch noch schaffen
sich da so drei oder vier viable Konkurrenten hochzuziehen,
die sonst niemals auch nur darüber nachgedacht hätten irgendwie da aufzudrehen,
das ist schon, also das ist schon was.
Twitter macht Elon Musk zum Millionär. Das wird noch richtig schön.
Das wird noch richtig schön. Wir haben Feedback bekommen.
Erstmal ein wichtiges Feedback, ich hatte glaube ich in der letzten Sendung
darüber gesprochen, bei Critical Mass Demonstrationen, an denen ich ja auch
immer gerne teilnehme, dass man dann quasi die, die, ähm...
Die Kreuzungen blockiert, damit die bescheuerten Autofahrer da nicht reinbrettern.
Das hatte ich beschrieben. Und da gibt es einen Begriff für.
Den hat Kathia mir erklärt und hat mir auch direkt eine Anleitung von der Critical
Mass Hamburg geschickt.
Das bezeichnet man als corken.
Wartende Fahrzeuge müssen die Kreuzungen frei halten, die werden gecorkt,
der Gegenverkehr nicht.
Wenn Feuerwehr oder Rettungswagen kommen, macht Platz und informiert andere.
Denkt immer daran, geschlossen zu fahren und Lücken zwischen den Fahrenden schnell
zu schließen. Bleibt ruhig und freundlich.
Es gibt nie genug Corker, also helft gerne mit. Aber auch nochmal,
nur bei einer critical mass. Also jetzt nicht in den Alltag,
in den Radfahreralltag ohne weiteres übernehmen.
Es gab ja gerade hier so eine riesen Fahrraddemo vor zwei Tagen.
War wieder eine, weil die in Berlin jetzt Fahrradwege abbauen wollen.
Wir haben ja jetzt so eine CDU Verkehrssenatorin.
Das geht so schief in diese, boah ey. Berlin ist in der Hand der Gruppe Wegner.
Seit so und so vielen Tagen.
Ist nicht von mir, der ist von Wetter, aber Gruppe Wegner ist einfach schon Premium.
Bist du wirklich erstaunlich, wenn die CDU dann mal wieder Regierungsbeteiligung
hat oder auch die FDP, wie schnell dann das Rückwärtsgewandte sofort sich Bahn
bricht. Also überhaupt keinerlei Verzögerung.
Boah, das sind so eine Horde Idioten, ey. Und dann haben sie,
genau, also was haben die gemacht? Wir haben die Friedrichstraße, eine der...
Ja, einfach eine Scheißstraße in Berlin, möchte man eigentlich sagen,
mit einem großen S-Bahnhof dran, wo sich auch eine U-Bahn langfährt und so,
also sehr zentrale Verkehrsstation von Berlin, auch historisch.
Und da führt eine Straße lang, die heißt Friedrichstraße und die war jetzt seit
einiger Zeit für den Autoverkehr gesperrt,
was zu einer super Situation, die jetzt ja geht von der Prachtstraße unter den
Linden ab, war einfach eine sehr sinnvolle Situation, dort keinen Verkehr zu haben.
Und der erste CDU, naja endlich, für die Freiheit!
Jetzt könnt ihr wieder hier auf der Friedrichstraße mit euren scheiß Autos stehen,
im Stau. Weil da kannst du ja gar nicht Autofahren.
Du wirst ja als normal denkender Mensch kommst du doch nicht auf die Idee,
also wenn der Navigationssystem sagt, jetzt fahren wir Friedrichstraße lang,
sagst du doch, geht doch gar nicht.
Friedrichstraße ist ein zu umfahrender Ort. Naja, und was haben sie noch?
Genau, da haben sie alle Radwegprojekte, haben sie gesagt, machen wir jetzt
nicht mehr, wenn dafür ein Parkplatz weichen muss.
Wie bescheuert kannst du sein, Tim?
Mir ist überhaupt nicht klar, wie doof man sein kann.
Die sind nur falsch verstanden worden, ganz klar.
Öffentlichkeit hat das nur nicht verstanden. Das wird ja nur überprüft,
weil es gibt ja auch noch andere Teilnehmer.
Naja, ich meine, guckt ihr die Heatmap an, wo die Autos angemeldet sind in Berlin
und wo die CDU gewählt wird, das ist schon ziemlich deckungsgleich.
Das mag nicht weiter überraschen und es ist so ein bisschen absurd,
aber das steht halt auch so ein bisschen für Deutschland, weil ich meine,
am Ende müssen wir uns halt auch klar machen, so haben die Leute gewählt.
Die Mehrheit will es halt haben. Naja, das ist halt so. Das ist die Klientel und...
Aber weißt du Tim, das sind doch Menschen, die haben einfach noch nicht das Licht gesehen.
Die werden das Licht auch nie sehen.
Es muss doch allen klar sein, dass es in einer Stadt wie Berlin und auch in
vielen anderen großen Städten einfach nur Irrsinn ist, diesen Straßenverkehr zu machen.
Und zwar nicht, und noch nicht einmal, Wenn du sagst, du machst das jetzt aus
ökologischen Erwägungen, selbst wenn man die mal weglässt.
Also bevor ich mich vertieft und besonders mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt habe,
auch da war mir nie die Idee nahe zu sagen, ich möchte mich in der Stadt Berlin mit einem Auto bewegen.
Ich hatte auch mal ein Auto. Dieses Auto stand so lange rum,
bis ich vergessen hatte, dass ich es hatte, weil ich, guck mal,
so eins hatte ich auch mal.
Ach scheiße, ist meins. Muss ich mal da wegstellen. Nee, stimmt gar nicht.
So lange kann das in Berlin gar nicht stehen, weil es wurde am laufenden Band
abgeschleppt, weil andauernd irgendjemand ein Halteverbotschild aufstellt.
Dadurch haben die mich dann immer mit ihren Briefen erinnert,
dass ich ein Auto irgendwo hingestellt habe.
Du kannst in dieser Stadt nicht ein Auto fahren, du musst völlig bescheuert sein.
Oder Tim, du hast ja ein Auto, wir haben ja letzte Sendung schon drüber gesprochen,
du hast ein Auto, weil du auch eine Familie hast und einen Wohnwagen und so,
wann hast du das letzte mal gesagt, ach wir fahren jetzt mal zum Dussmann an der Friedrichstraße?
Mit dem Auto.
Erzähl was dir nicht wahr. Ja, ich meine es gibt so viele Aspekte,
warum es besser wäre den Autoverkehr zurückzudrängen,
aber der erschlagenste, das ist ja das Absurde, wäre,
dass eigentlich alle Beispiele der Welt, wo das getan wurde,
wo man gesagt hat, Autos raus aus der Stadt, dass das vor allem einen wirtschaftlichen
Aufschwung für die City bedeutet.
Und die sogenannte Partei der Wirtschaft, checkt das halt nicht.
Naja es ist halt einfach ein schwieriger Prozess, aber wie auch immer ist es
immer einfach das so auf einzelne Player zu machen,
aber das Hauptproblem ist, unsere Gesellschaft ist nicht so weit und die Deutschen
sind zu stubborn und sind einfach auch wirklich nicht einfach lernfähig, ja also.
Also ich kann mich in so eine Parallelwelt reinversetzen, wo du so irgendwann
mal so in deinem Leben eine falsche Entscheidung getroffen hast und gesagt hast,
ich fahr jetzt mit dem Auto in Berlin rum.
Und die Entscheidung aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen nie wieder in Frage gestellt
hast und dann kann ich mir echt vorstellen,
dass du da irgendwie so im Stau sitzt und dann siehst du irgendwie so jemanden,
der einen Parkplatz wegmacht und dann drehst du natürlich durch und sagst so
ey, hier könnte dich noch ein wegmachen, ich brauche einen Parkplatz oder soll
ich jetzt hier in einem Auto, soll ich hier bei der Fahrt schlafen oder so,
ich komme ja hier sonst auch nicht raus.
Aber du aber das man und was sind die was sind die großen ist die großen Beispiele
der der stadtzentrierteren Städte so so absolut lebens lebenslose überhaupt
unattraktive Orte wie Paris,
Amsterdam, Amsterdam, wo wir jetzt zum Urlaub hinfahren mit unserem Auto,
um dann da mit dem Fahrrad durch die Gegend zu fahren, schöner Urlaub,
jetzt fahren wir mit dem Auto zurück.
Katastrophe.
Katastrophe. Aber wir müssen uns darüber Gedanken machen, da sind wir auch schon
fast beim nächsten Feedback, wie kriegt man die Gesellschaft mitgenommen auf diesen Gedanken?
Was kann man für Denkangebote machen hier, um sozusagen zum Erfolg zu kommen?
Genau, und über diese Denkangebote haben wir ja in der letzten Sendung gesprochen,
nachdem wir jetzt übrigens ausgelöst, also ausgelöst durch die Überwachungen
der letzten Generation und die Einstufungsversuche der letzten Generation als
kriminelle Vereinigung,
seitdem reden wir seit einiger Zeit über die letzte Generation,
Haben wir dann darüber gesprochen, ob denn die Mittel der letzten Generation
geeignet sind, die Mehrheit der Menschen von ihren Zielen zu überzeugen.
Und wir hatten, der Tim ja eher schon länger, auch in den vorhergehenden Sendungen, Zweifel.
Zweifel, dass das eine Methode ist, die dazu führt, dass eine Mehrheit sich
den Zielen der letzten Generation anschließt.
Dafür haben wir jetzt einen Riesenschwall an Feedback bekommen,
was uns einfällt, diese Kritik anzubringen, nachdem wir vorher einen Riesenschwall
an Feedback hatten, was uns einfällt, diese Arschlöcher von der letzten Generation
uns mit denen zu solidarisieren.
Insofern bin ich super zufrieden mit mir.
Das Wattemass machst du richtig, fühlt sich immer jemand getroffen,
aber es gab jetzt am 26.06.
Eine Umfrage, das ist eine Umfrage des SWR, ich glaube über YouGov oder wo die sowas machen.
Und ja, 85% der Befragten lehnen die Protestform ab.
Und das ist natürlich, ja, da muss man sich einfach mit auseinandersetzen.
In Deutschland?
Ja klar, in anderen Ländern gibt es sicherlich klügere Menschen,
die vielleicht auch aufgrund einer klügeren Verkehrspolitik nicht so stark von
solchen Blockaden betroffen sind.
Also 85 Prozent der Befragten halten das Blockieren von Straßenverkehr für nicht gerechtfertigt.
Nur jeder Achte hält die Sachen für gerechtfertigt.
Zustimmung und jetzt gegenüber früheren Umfragen weiter gesunken.
Das ist ja hier, diesen Trend muss man natürlich auch nochmal sagen.
2019 hatten die noch 24 Prozent Unterstützung, die die Aktion für gerechtfertigt hielten.
Und ja, das ist leider das Fazit, was man dazu unterziehen muss.
Das heißt aber, und das muss ich, glaube ich, einigen Leuten immer wieder erklären,
insofern mache ich das auch gerne, nicht, dass wir ihre Ziele nicht richtig fänden.
Wir haben ja in der letzten Sendung sehr viel uns darum bemüht,
Mittel und Zweck zu trennen.
Und nicht, der Zweck heiligt eben nicht alle Mittel, beziehungsweise vielleicht
tut er es sogar, aber man muss sich dann eben irgendwann auch fragen,
ob man mit seinen Mitteln dem Zweck denn wirklich näher kommt oder nicht.
Und das ist eine Reflexion, die notwendig ist und deswegen werden ja jetzt auch
die Privatjets bunt angemalt, statt der Verkehr gesperrt.
Auf jeden Fall fand ich es wirklich auffällig, wenn ihr zwei Sendungen lang
die Autofahrer-Kartoffeln in den Kommentaren habt und auf einmal dann so,
was fällt euch ein, die letzte Generation zu kritisieren,
da hab ich irgendwie den Eindruck, dass das, ja, also weiß ich nicht,
da hab ich irgendwie nicht den
Eindruck, dass meine Ausführung vollständig gefolgt wurde oder so, naja.
Hast du das Gefühl öfter?
Ich würde mir manchmal schon...
Manchmal hab ich den Eindruck, dass Leute mich nicht verstehen.
Dann fang ich einfach an mich zu wiederholen. Hab ich bei der Arbeit häufiger mal.
Na gut. Vielleicht an der Stelle ein Kommentar, den wir erhalten haben von Einhörer.
Der kriegt jetzt auf die Fresse. Der kriegt jetzt aber, der kriegt richtig Kontraheien.
Er schreibt, Vorsicht, anekdotische Evidenz, schonmal schöne Einschränkung.
In meinem Umfeld richtet die letzte Generation nichts als Schaden an.
Kurz zu mir, mir ist Umweltschutz sehr wichtig, habe vor ein paar Jahren mein
Auto verkauft und bin gänzlich aufs Fahrrad umgestiegen, obwohl ich in einer
ziemlich fahrradunfreundlichen Gegend wohne und das Auto hier definitiv gewinnt.
Staus sind hier kein Thema, wenig Öffis. Ich habe auch immer versucht,
mein direktes Umfeld da ein wenig mitzuziehen, was teilweise auch echt gut geklappt hat.
Meine Eltern nehmen mittlerweile für die kurzen Strecken auch das Fahrrad,
haben nur noch ein Auto und Themen wie Wärmepumpe und Solarinstallation und
grüne Energie wurden sehr positiv bewertet.
Seit die letzte Generation sich aber durch die Medien durchprofiliert,
merke ich, wie in der gesamten Nachbarschaft, sowohl bei mir als auch im familiären
Umfeld, die Situation vergiftet ist.
Begriffe, die vorher positiv besetzt waren, sind das nun nicht mehr und das
alles führt nun dazu, dass bei Umweltthemen auch bei meiner Verwandtschaft langsam
wieder die Augen gerollt werden. Selbst bei Themen, denen man vorher klar positiv gegenüberstand.
Klar kann man jetzt sagen, jeder der sich so verhält ist doof etc.,
aber dieses ständige sich selbst nur auf die Schulter klopfen und wie doof nicht
die ganzen blöden Menschen sind, die da so extrem reagieren,
hat schon langsam etwas Masturbatorisches.
Für mich stellt die letzte Generation damit ein reines Negativ für den Umweltschutz
dar und es ist mehr als bedauerlich und ärgerlich, dass diese Gruppe nun zum
Gesicht des Umweltschutzes wird.
Ja also es wurde ja auch darauf hingewiesen um das noch gleich hinterher zu
werfen so dass zum Beispiel in Amsterdam was wir jetzt gerade als Beispiel genannt
hatten ja die Verkehrswende einst auch mit Straßenblockaden durchgeführt wurde.
Oh. Ja unter anderem zumindest so.
Bis dann alle auf die Hollandräder umgestiegen sind um an den Blockaden vorbeizufahren
oder was? Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Ich weiß da nicht so viel darüber wie das jetzt konkret gelaufen ist,
aber ich hab so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass das unter Umständen dann aber
auch um eine andere gesellschaftliche Bewegung gehandelt hat.
Während die letzte Generation halt in seinem ganzen Auftreten und Gehabe dann doch sehr, ich sag mal.
Typisch linken Demonstrationshabitus folgt, der sicherlich da auch nochmal erschwerend
hinzukommt, wenn das auch sicherlich nicht das einzige Problem dabei ist.
Aber Holland und Amsterdam ist nicht Deutschland. Man muss immer schauen,
wo sind wir, was sind hier die Themen und die Ansichten.
Hatten wir auch noch einen längeren Kommentar von Robert, der auch so ein bisschen sagte, ne?
Ich hätte das auch ein bisschen angefangen, also sagen wir mal,
die Aktivitäten des CCC, der ja in diesem Jahr übrigens 42 Jahre dann alt wird,
die sind ja auch in einem gewissermaßen steten Wandel.
Ja, wir machen nicht immer das Gleiche, einfach weil der Erfolg einer Aktion
so ein bisschen eben auch von dem,
von dem Kontext abhängt, in dem sie stattfindet und eine Aktion selber sich eben auch abnutzt,
ja, sodass du dich da die ganze Zeit neu erfinden musst,
ob du, was weiß ich, ob du das, ob du hier jetzt die Schadsoftware analysierst
und releasest mit beispielsweise mit dem Staatstrojaner,
was damals ein weltweiter fetter Scoop war und inzwischen eine Aktivität,
die immer noch enorm wichtig ist, auch entsprechende Aufmerksamkeit bekommt,
aber die inzwischen viel wichtiger ist in der, in der, in der,
oder eher so ein Prozess ist, der quasi standardmäßig ist.
Es wird jetzt nicht mehr, kommt jetzt nicht mehr in der Tagesschau,
wenn der Citizen Lab mal wieder eine Schadsoftware analysiert hat.
Insofern nutzt sich das ab und du musst dann andere Wege gehen.
Dann bist du eben zum Beispiel, wie der Thorsten eben letztes Jahr war das glaube
ich bei einer Anhörung im Europaparlament im Pegasus Untersuchungsausschuss,
weil du immer gucken musst, in welchem Umfeld befinden wir uns gerade und wie muss ich hier agieren?
Wie muss ich hier vielleicht auch überraschen?
Wie muss ich hier Sympathiepunkte sammeln?
Da hat mal jemand einen Vortrag beim CCC Kongress drüber gehalten unter dem
Titel Politik hacken, den kann ich dazu immer noch mal empfehlen.
Aber um mal wieder zu der letzten Generation zu kommen,
es kommt nämlich jetzt natürlich raus, das war ja auch das, wo wir anfingen
mit dem als kriminelle Vereinigung einstufen,
das machen die hauptsächlich, um das Ermittlungsverfahren zu haben und was kommt
raus, die bayerische Polizei hat seit Oktober 2022.
13 Telefonanschlüsse der letzten Generation überwacht.
Auch das offizielle Presse-Telefon, das Handy von Carla Hinrichs,
die Sprecherin, das wurde abgehört, da wird der Telefon abgehört, völlig irre.
Ende Mai waren ja dann die Razzien, über die wir auch berichtet hatten,
und da geht es eben um diesen Vorwurf krimineller Vereinigung,
es ist nicht klar, ob die Überwachung zu dem Zeitpunkt noch stattfand.
Aber ja, die gehen richtig, richtig übel gegen die vor und ich kann dieses Vorgehen
in keiner Form nachvollziehen,
finde das absolut unangemessen und echt, Telefonate mit der Presse abzuhören,
da kannst du nun wirklich nicht erwarten, also das kannst du in keiner Form rechtfertigen.
Also mal angenommen, die wären in irgendeiner Form kriminell, was sie ja nicht sind.
Mal angenommen, die würden bewusst zum Zwecke des Begehens von Straftaten existieren
und so weiter, das alles angenommen, dann würdest du garantiert keine Hinweise,
Beweise darüber auf der offiziellen Presse-Hotline hören.
Dass die so sagen, ey, niemand sagt, aber nächste Woche brauchen wir eine Bank
aus als Zeichen gegen den Klimawandel. Das ist ja totaler Unsinn.
Der Eingriff in die Privatsphäre ist ja nochmal was anderes,
den können sie aber wenigstens, den können sie vielleicht noch irgendwo sich
aus den Gesetzen, die sie da anwenden, konstruieren.
Aber die Pressenummer abzuhören ist ein Angriff auf die Pressefreiheit und der
ist sicherlich an dieser Stelle durch nichts zu rechtfertigen.
Gleichzeitig bei den Personen ist es auch, glaube ich, ist es sehr...
Wie soll man das sagen? Es ist sehr schwierig, denke ich, die Verhältnismäßigkeit
dieser Maßnahme mir zu erklären und ich finde es absolut daneben.
Ich würde aber sagen, es ist, die werden damit juristisch zumindest durchkommen.
Dass sie jetzt sagen, naja, wir haben doch hier strafbare Nötigung oder Verdacht
der Nötigung, Ermittlungsverfahren wegen krimineller Vereinigung und so weiter.
Weiter, da müssen wir doch die Leute abhören. Da würde ich jetzt schätzen,
dass höchstens in Einzelfällen es gelingt,
die Maßnahme nachher als nicht rechtmäßig am Ende zurückzuweisen,
weil die es nun mal dürfen und weil sie es nun mal unter bestimmten Voraussetzungen
dürfen und die werden sich wahrscheinlich Mühe gegeben haben,
diese Voraussetzungen zu argumentieren.
Allerdings muss man auch sagen, in Bayern haben sie da keine großen Schwierigkeiten,
denn Bayern ist Anführerin der Statistik der Telekommunikationsüberwachung. Die haben 2020,
3216 Erstanordnungen gemacht und 460 Verlängerungen.
Das heißt irgendwie so bayerische Polizei hört irgendwie im Schnitt so 3.600.
Telefonanschlüsse ab.
Und davon ging es bei in 124 dieser Verfahren um Straftaten gegen die öffentliche
Ordnung, wo dann eben auch kriminelle Vereinigung zugehört.
Und die restlichen 3.000 noch, das war dann irgendwie...
Weiß der Geier, was die Bayern sich da einfallen lassen. Ich glaube,
da musst du auch nicht viel machen, damit die dich abhören. Aber ja,
das Vorgehen gegen die Gruppe ist absolut unwürdig.
Und deswegen berichten wir hier auch darüber.
Genau. Gut. Dann verlassen wir aber das Thema mal und haben noch Feedback zu AIDAS.
Ja, liest doch mal den Kommentar von Harm vor.
Genau. Harm Otten sagte uns in seinem Kommentar. Guten Morgen Linus, Tim und Leserinnen.
Hier eine Einladung zu konstruktiven Kommentaren zu AIDAS.
Ich finde es sicher richtig, dass eine Überidentifizierung als starkes Risiko
reinspielt. Was sind weitere Risiken?
Inwiefern kannst du die technischen Möglichkeiten zur Statusabfrage von Aufenthaltsstatus,
Alter oder Identifikation gegenüber, beispielsweise Sozialversicherungen an
EU kommen und Bundesregierung vermitteln, Linus?
Vorteile könnten auch sein. A, Daten würden strukturiert auch von Europäern
genutzt, neben Swift Flugdaten, Internet suchen und OpenAI-Anfragen,
die ja typischerweise in Nordamerika analysiert werden.
B. Keine nationale Bank-ID mehr, sodass ich mein schwedisches Kronenkonto mit
dem deutschen Reisepass als Login-Pass-Key öffnen kann, auch wenn ich in Dänemark wohne.
C. Breite Anwendungen, aber auch eindeutige Grenzsetzungen bei öffentlichen,
teilöffentlichen und privaten Anbietern, etwa, dass der Statusabfrageansatz
verpflichtend ist, auch bei Krankenversicherung, Ausländerbehörde und Renten-
und Sozialhilfeanspruch.
Alle können nur auf Teilbereiche zugreifen. Ich bekomme etwa die Nachricht auf sundhit.dk,
wenn andere als meine Hausärztin auf Testergebnisse oder Medizinrezepte,
alles digital und papierlos, zugreifen. Euer treuer Hörer.
Moment, da würde ich jetzt fragen, bekommt er diese Nachricht?
Den Eindruck habe ich...
Gesundheit.dk.
Ist wahrscheinlich gesundheitsportal in Dänemark.
Ein digitales Innenkrankentum Gesundheitswesen.
Das ist ja die anderen Länder, die das mit der Digitalisierung so ein bisschen
mehr verinnerlicht haben, weiß ja wie das läuft.
Ja also im Kern ist das ja hier sozusagen das Argument mit, wenn man es richtig
macht, dann könnte es ja auch richtig toll sein.
Das unterstreiche ich auch total. Ähnliches habe ich auch schon aus Holland gehört.
Leute, die da am Gesundheitssystem teilnehmen und der Digitalisierung eine Menge
abgewinnen können, weil es halt schlicht alles einfacher wird.
Aber wir sind hier dann doch manchmal auch ein bisschen zu sehr verrannt und blockiert bei allem.
Wie ist es hier in den besten von beiden Wörtern?
So viel, schön, dass, also diese Diskussion werden wir weiter führen.
Ich bin mir auch sicher, dass wir da in naher Zukunft nochmal mit Thomas drüber
sprechen, wenn dieses Thema sich weiterentwickelt.
Wir haben noch einen wunderschönen Kommentar. Das ist mein Lieblingskommentar
diese Woche. Der ist von Kantorkel.
Wir haben ja letzte Woche über die Verlinkung von links unten gesprochen,
ja, auch das ein Thema, was uns länger begleitet.
Kurz zur Erinnerung, es gab eine Webseite, die hieß links unten in die Media,
diese wurde verboten, und zwar kann man die Webseite einfach verbieten,
also hat man den Betreiberinnen unterstellt, eine kriminelle Vereinigung zu sein, ja.
Damit dann diesen Verein verboten und somit eben durch das Vereinsverbot meinte
man dann eben auch die Webseite verbieten zu können.
Darüber wurde berichtet, da in diesem Rahmen wurde ein Archiv verlinkt und dafür
soll der Radiosender, Radio 3 Gland jetzt irgendwie Ärger bekommen.
So, jetzt sagt Kat Horkel, kommentiert dazu.
Was haben die Gewerkschaft der Polizei Mecklenburg-Vorpommern,
die Deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft, Landesverband Hamburg, das Bundesministerium
des Innern und für Heimat sowie das Innenministerium Sachsen gemeinsam.
Sachdienlicher Hinweis, sie alle linken auf links unten.
Zum Teil wird sogar auf das geheime Darknet-Angebot der Vereinigung hingewiesen.
Tweet von gdv-mp, Tatseitpunkt 25.08.2017, depol.g Hamburg, 28.01.2020,
bmi-bund, 21.05.2018.
Smi-sachsen, 25.08.2017.
Nach meinem Kenntnisstand hat die Staatsanwaltschaft Karlsruhe Kenntnis von
den Sachverhalten, jedoch wurden offenbar noch keine Durchsuchungsmaßnahmen eingeleitet.
Ja, schön, finde ich wirklich schön. Ja, es ist einfach genau das ist es.
Und ja, was soll man dazu noch sagen? DS sagt auch, man müsste konsequenterweise
natürlich auch noch Strafanzeige gegen Google stellen, weil wenn man links unten
bei Google eingibt, linken die da hin.
Technische Geräte, den CEOs wegnehmen, alle Rechner wegnehmen.
Sehr schön ist auch dieser Twitter-Thread, der dann auch verlinkt ist,
wo sich irgend so ein Hyperventilierer aufregt,
so warum ist diese linke Hassseite immer noch online,
Lattenzauern, Antifa, Linksterror, bla, und dann das Bundesministerium des Innern
so einfach so ja Infos hier so,
und dann auf einen weiteren Hinweis dann so, sie verwechseln scheinbar die Webseiten,
verboten wurde die unter der OL, links unten in die Media Org.
Und die im TOR-Netzwerk unter der Onion-Adresse abrufbare Internetseite des Vereins. Das ist schön.
Das ist wirklich super. Funktioniert zwar nicht mehr, die Onion-Adresse, aber so ist es.
Alle verbieten, alle gleich festnehmen, diese bösen Verlinker.
Ja, ich meine, was soll das? Absurder wird es doch heute nicht mehr.
Ja. Ja.
Oder vielleicht doch.
Kommen wir vielleicht zum nächsten Feedbackpunkt. Da geht's nochmal um Cell Broadcast. Wir hatten den Kommentar von Paul gehabt, der so beschrieben hat, dass er so etwas ein Überangebot an Nachrichten bekommt, hat aber dann nur von in unserem Land gesprochen und nicht gesagt welches.
Funktioniert insbesondere gut, wenn das tatsächliche Mobilfunknetz eh gerade am
knacken ist und das ist ein klassischer Spaß.
So, damit sind wir Feedback durch. Kommen wir zur Chat-Kontrolle.
Was gibt es denn Neues? Ja, das geht ja wirklich in 100 Runden.
Ich denke, die nächste wichtigste T-Abstimmung ist dann im Liebe-Ausschuss am 21.09.
Jetzt wurde die Abschlussempfehlung beschlossen, und zwar im Binnenmarktausschuss,
das ist der Imco, und der hat teils weitreichende Änderungen an dem Verordnungsentwurf empfohlen.
Und diese Stellungnahme vom Imco ist aber für den federführenden Ausschuss Liebe,
verbindlich, bietet aber eine ganz gute Orientierung.
Insgesamt will glücklicherweise schon der Binnenmarktausschuss diesem Ding einige Giftszähne ziehen.
Die verpflichtende Altersverifikation soll idealerweise gestrichen werden.
Das klingt ganz gut. Und die App Store Zensur für Jugendliche soll gestrichten werden,
das heißt, diesen ganzen Altersverifikationsteil, der da immer,
der ja auch noch mitschwimmt bei der ganzen Sache,
der soll raus, nicht gestrichen werden sollen, aber Ideen wie Netz sperren und
die Nachrichten und Chat-Kontrolle.
Ja, die falls wir sie nicht streichen.
Also ich würde das jetzt gar nicht so detailliert alles auseinandernehmen,
weil es wie gesagt so ein Zwischenstand ist,
der zunächst einmal halbwegs okay ist,
ja, also der sich zumindest in die richtige Richtung bewegt,
aber der diese Grundsatzidee,
der der Chat-Kontrolle eben immer noch nicht,
noch nicht da raus streicht und da werden,
gibt es jetzt entsprechend auch eine Reihe von, von Reaktionen,
offenen Briefen der Wissenschaft, die also sagen,
hier Leute, das ist weiterhin eine sehr schlechte Idee, insbesondere das Client-Side-Scanning,
also das Scannen auf den Endgeräten, was ja das Entscheidende bei der Chat-Kontrolle ist.
Und ja, die Technologien, die dabei zum Einsatz kommen sollen,
haben schwere Mängel und sind anfällig für Angriffe.
Die Auswirkungen oder die technische Auswirkung ist die Schwächung der Ende-zu-Ende
Verschlüsselung und am Ende ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass das Ganze überhaupt
einen Effekt haben kann.
Und das muss natürlich jetzt leider von immer wieder unterschiedlichen Leuten vorgebracht werden,
um halt auch dieses fundamentale Problem halt mal aufrechtzuerhalten und auch
immer wieder in die Erinnerung zu rufen.
Weil Leute, wenn eine fundamental schlechte Idee,
die kann man dann, dann hast du, wenn du die durchdrückst und dann kommt hier so ein Ausschuss,
der drei, vier Giftszähne von der Schlange zieht, aber die Schlange ist ein
Hai und hat 100 Zähne, ja, dann ist halt eine kleine Verbesserung nicht die
Lösung des Grundproblems leider.
Insofern bleibt es spannend und wir können weiter hoffen, dass hier der breite
Protest von informierten Leuten noch mehr Effekt haben wird,
diesen Kram zu bekämpfen.
Ja, es dauert immer eine Weile bis sich solche ganz grundlegenden Dinge da wirklich
rum sprechen, aber das ist halt auch ein Problem mit dem technischen Grundverständnis.
Es ist schwierig eins zu erhalten, wenn man noch keins hat.
Tja und das ist ne, also Chatkontrolle soll weiterhin verdachtslos sein.
Es ist komplette Durchleuchtung von Cloudspeichern, Massenüberwachung,
privater Fotos, Briefgeheimnis, komplett verloren, solange du nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselst.
Also das sind dann so die Dicke, dass die sagen, ja gut.
Ja gut, also pass auf, alles was nicht verschlüsselt ist, durchsuchen wir, ja.
Ist halt auch eine geile Message, ja, also wie geil ist dein Gesetz denn noch,
wenn die Idee, warum sie es überhaupt wollten, ist ja, dass es Verschlüsselung gibt, ja.
Und jetzt machen sie daraus halt irgendwie so ein Werbeprogramm für Verschlüsselung,
was es ohnehin geworden wäre, ne.
Also die widersprechen sich ja auch selber und du merkst natürlich auch,
dass die jetzt in so einer, dass die in einer Phase des too much invested to quit sind.
Diese Ilva Johansson, die rennt jetzt seit zwei Jahren mit diesem Bullshit durch
die Gegend und die kann natürlich nicht mehr nicht das entscheiden.
Also es muss jetzt ein Prozess, es muss für sie irgendein,
irgendetwas beschlossen werden, was ihre Initiative da ist, wo sie sich dann
hinstellen kann und sagt, Leute, ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen,
wie viele Kinder ich heute gerettet habe, ne. Das muss passieren.
Und inhaltlich ist es längst scheiß, also gewissermaßen scheißegal,
was da drin steht, Hauptsache sie kommt irgendwie gesichtswand aus der Nummer raus.
Aber es muss am Ende muss ein Blatt Papier unterschrieben werden und jetzt müssen wir uns überlegen,
ob wir es hinkriegen, dann noch möglichst wenig Schädliches draufzuschreiben,
damit diese, seien wir ehrlich,
inzwischen längst nur noch aus Ego und politischem Kalkül geführte Auseinandersetzung,
Die arbeitet jetzt seit wie vielen Jahren an dem Moment,
dass sie dann irgendwie eine viertel Minute in der Tagesschau ist und sagen
kann, aber eben auch in ganz Europa in den Nachrichten ist und sagen kann,
historischer Moment, endlich werden in Europa die Kinder geschützt.
Da arbeitet die seit Jahren drauf hin und das wird die, den wird die haben müssen.
Eine Möglichkeit wäre, jetzt tatsächliche Kinderschutzmaßnahmen da reinzuschreiben,
dem verwehren sie sich aber wiederum, ja. Das ist eine...
Ich spüre deinen Schmerz.
Vielleicht können wir sagen, wir machen Kinderschutz nur, wenn wir dafür Parkplätze opfern.
Ich weiß es nicht, es ist so verrückt, ne.
Und das in einer Zeit, wo,
wenn du dir jetzt mal anhörst, wir jetzt nicht in andere Politikbereiche abgleiten,
aber so was jetzt so, sagen wir mal Schutzmaßnahmen für Kinder,
beispielsweise vor Armut oder so, das interessiert hier keine Sau,
ne? Das interessiert hier keine Sau.
So was haben wir noch?
DSGVO.
Das weißt du aber wofür das steht ne? Ja.
Datenschutzgrundverordnung. Viele kriegen die Abkürzung nicht auf die Kette
aber bei mir sitzt es mittlerweile fest drin also man kann schnell durcheinander kommen, ich nicht mehr.
Grundverordnung. Vor allem hat auch viel damit zu tun, dass ich einfach das
Prinzip Grundverordnung gelernt habe.
Was eigentlich auch für dich so ein furchtbares Wort ist. Grundverordnung,
Grundverordnung, Grundverordnung. Aber das ist halt das stärkste Schwert der EU.
Und dann brauchen wir nur noch Datenschutz davor. Ja klar also ich meine Grundverordnung
heißt ja für alle unmittelbar bindend. Wenn eine Grundverordnung beschlossen
wird dann gilt das sofort und muss nicht ratifiziert werden.
Während halt die ganzen sonstigen Sachen halt nur Empfehlungen sind beziehungsweise,
wie heißt nochmal gleich das ging schon zur Grundverordnung,
die, siehst du mal, toll ne ich hab's voll drauf.
Ist sie fair?
Darfschein? Nein.
Also, ich komm gleich drauf. Aber die andere Sache ist ja, das muss dann alles
erstmal nur in die Richtlinie. Wenn die Richtlinie, eine EU-Richtlinie beschlossen
wird, dann ist es halt genau das. Das ist eine Richtlinie.
Da hast du als Staat, als Mitgliedsstaat innerhalb einer akzeptablen Zeit deinen
Gesetzesrahmen darauf anzupassen, dass die Vorgaben dieser Richtlinie erfüllt werden.
Aber das ist sozusagen nicht von heute auf morgen genau so und überall gleich,
sondern es ist dann in jedem Land an die jeweilige Gesetzeslage angepasst in
irgendeiner Form umgesetzt,
dann gibt es auch Länder die sagen so nee machen wir nicht, dann wirst du da
verklagt, dann kriegst du Strafzahlung und irgendwann kommt dann was und dann
hast du es umgesetzt und dann wird dann aber später nochmal geklagt und festgestellt,
dass du die Richtlinie gar nicht richtig umgesetzt hast.
Das kann alles lange dauern, aber die Grundverordnung, die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung
insbesondere, war quasi ab Tag 1 auch sofort genau die und damit war ganz klar
festgelegt, diese Regeln gelten jetzt und die brechen im Zweifelsfall auch euer
lokales, nationales Gesetz.
Deswegen gibt es auch nicht so viele davon, von den Grundverordnungen.
Klar, aber umso schöner, dass wir eine haben und die hat ja jetzt,
wir haben sie ja kürzlich noch gewürdigt, zehn Jahre alt, fünf Jahre alt, so war es genau.
Und jetzt haben wir auch behandelt den Verein Neub, letzte Woche glaube ich
auch noch mal, die hatten ja so eine, oder letzte Sendung, hatten irgendwie
so einen Job gesucht, Ruby on Rails Coder haben die gesucht.
Könnt ihr aber nochmal gucken, wenn ihr euch da einbringen möchtet.
So, jetzt, und diese Verfahren sind immer so kompliziert, ich werde das jetzt,
glaube ich, einfach bei Neub ablesen.
Also der EuGH hat Metas DSGVO-Ansatz, mit anderen Worten, deren Versuch die
DSGVO zu umgehen, als illegal abgeurteilt.
Und damit folgen sie der Auffassung von Neub, none of your business und EDSA.
Jetzt müssen wir gucken, wer EDSA ist.
European Data Protection Board.
Europäischer Datenschutzausschuss.
Datenschutzausschuss, okay, alles klar, verstehe. Die haben also gesagt,
pass mal auf, so wie ihr meint, wie diese Grundverordnung gemeint ist,
meinen wir, ist die gar nicht gemeint.
Und das ist ein relativ wichtiger Punkt,
weil META auf Basis dieser Auslegung der DSGVO die ganzen personenbezogenen Daten,
die sie verwenden, für andere Dinge als die Bereitstellung des Kernproduktes
nicht ohne weitere Zustimmung verwenden dürfen.
Zum Beispiel für Werbung oder die Zusammenlegung der Nutzung personenbezogener
Daten zwischen den Diensten. Da brauchen Sie wieder eine freie Zustimmung der Nutzerin.
Im Prinzip ist es ja, wenn ich
das jetzt mal leidenhaft und wahrscheinlich dadurch etwas falsch erkläre.
DSGVO erlaubt vieles oder alles an Datenverarbeitung, was dir so einfällt,
aber du brauchst die informierte Zustimmung.
Das heißt, es muss sichergestellt werden, dir wurde erklärt,
was da jetzt passiert, wenn du auf den Knopf drückst und du hast dann diese
Entscheidung dokumentierbar informiert getroffen.
Und jetzt geht natürlich Facebook hin und versucht natürlich
irgendwie alles zusammenzubinden und sagt hier pass auf Facebook sign up und
dann steht irgendwo in tausenden von Paragraphen steht irgendwo drin wir machen
alles Mögliche und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Sie versuchen natürlich alles, um im Prinzip schon zu Beginn mit der ersten
Einwilligung so einen carte blanche zu haben.
Und das wiederum wird Ihnen jetzt also ausgelegt,
als dass Sie für die Verarbeitung der Daten, die Sie vornehmen,
keine gültige Rechtsgrundlage haben, weil Sie die Einwilligung nicht einholen.
Schwierig, ne? Also letztendlich, sie machen Dinge,
um die Verpflichtung zu umgehen, eine Einwilligung für Tracking und Online-Werbung
einzuholen, hat Meta argumentiert, dass die Werbung Teil des Dienstes ist,
den es den Nutzerinnen vertraglich schuldet.
Die haben also im Prinzip gesagt, was wir machen ist, du kannst dich hier anmelden
und so und dann kriegst du Werbung.
Super, ne? Willste, ne? Dann melde dich mal hier an. Und damit haben sie quasi
dieses ganze Tracking und Werbung als Teil einer Dienstleistung an den Nutzer argumentieren wollen.
Und daraus dann gemacht, naja, das ist ja eine vertragliche Notwendigkeit,
um überhaupt den Dienst zu... Wir haben den Leuten ja Werbung versprochen.
Wir können denen ja jetzt nicht auf einmal keine Werbung mehr geben.
Die laufen schreiend nach Hause, wenn sie irgendwie keine Werbung sehen.
Ich meine stell dir mal vor du würdest wirklich durch Facebook durchsurfen und
eine Stunde lang keine Werbung sehen, das würde wahrscheinlich schon dazu führen,
dass die Leute langsam etwas verstört werden.
Ich weiß nicht mehr was ich kaufen soll.
Dann haben sie irgendwann, das wurde ihnen schon gesagt,
das kannst du so nicht machen, dann sind sie zum berechtigten Interesse gewechselt,
um dann eben zu sagen, naja, wir haben ja ein berechtigtes Interesse für die
Werbung nach Artikel 6 Absatz 1 F DSGVO und da steht,
der Eugen hat zwar nicht ausgeschlossen, dass ein solches berechtigtes Interesse
bestehen kann, Aber die große Bereitstellung von Werbung wiegt nicht stärker
als die Rechte der Nutzer.
Somit dürfen die nur Werbung schalten oder personalisierte Werbung und das ganze
Tracking machen, wenn eine freiwillige Einwilligung Ja-Nein vorliegt.
Max Schrems, anstatt eine Ja-Nein Option für personalisierte Werbung zu haben,
haben Sie die Einwilligungsklausel einfach in die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen verschoben.
Das ist nicht nur unfair, sondern eindeutig illegal.
Uns ist kein anderes Unternehmen bekannt, das auf derart arrogante Art und Weise
die DSGVO ignoriert und zum Urteil sagt, Max, dies ist ein schwerer Schlag für
Meta, aber auch für andere Online-Werbeunternehmen.
Er stellt klar, dass verschiedene juristische Ansätze der Branche zur Umgehung
der DSGVO Null und nichtig sind.
Und ich glaube, da kann man auch sagen, das Gefühl hatte man ja auch, ja?
Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie jemanden auf der Straße ansprichst und sagst,
was sagst du zu DSGVO, dann werden die in der Regel sagen, ja,
das ist irgendwie nervig, ne?
Und ich spüre da jetzt nichts von. Also in der Breite insbesondere,
hier ja klar messbar bei Facebook, ist jetzt nicht angekommen,
dass die Nutzerinnen auf einmal irgendwie Rechte haben,
die sie sinnvoll, wirksam und mit einer nicht einen Tennisarm Risiko bergenden
Anzahl von Klicks in irgendeiner Form auch wahrnehmen können.
Was dem Pferd die Bremse ist dem Zuck die Schremse. Also der Typ ist wirklich
der Schmerzmarsch, oder?
Ich glaube, wenn du sagst hier Zuckerberg Käfig-Match mit Max Schrems,
der steht fünf Minuten vor der Tür mit so einem Baseball-Schläger,
wo so ein Zimmermannsnagel durchgeschlagen ist, weißt du?
Das ist schon wirklich, aber das Lustige ist ja einerseits,
wenn man sich jetzt so Max Schrems und die Neubes anschaut,
einerseits denkst du natürlich, gut irre, dass so eine kleine Gruppe um aufgewächsten Juristen,
damals ja angefangen als Jurastudenten, erschaffen diesen Milliardenkonzern
seit Jahren irgendwie so mit so einem kleinen Piekefinger vor sich her zu treiben, weißt du so?
Mähp, mähp.
Und dann denkst du irgendwie so, boah Wahnsinn, ne? Und die sitzen da mit ein
paar Leuten, die sind sicherlich ja ganz okay gefundet, kann man spenden.
Kann man Mitglied werden, bin ich auch.
Aber gleichzeitig findet dann halt Lee so, naja, also die halten sich halt sehr
dreist einfach an geltende Gesetze nicht und so dreist haben wir es auch noch nicht gesehen.
Dann brauchst du halt einfach nur ein paar Jahre Geduld, bis es dann eben ein
entsprechendes EuGH-Urteil gibt.
Ja, leider betrifft das mal wieder Rechte, die ich gar nicht habe, aber immerhin.
Oder Rechte die bei mir gar nicht verletzt werden, als nicht Facebooker,
aber wer weiß, vielleicht wenn wir dann demnächst alle bei Threads sind,
wenn wir unsere Ergüsse threaten, dann können wir vielleicht da noch ein paar
DSGVO Einwilligungen schremsen.
Ich find's schön wie Threads eigentlich ja auch mit T geschrieben sich genauso anhört.
Treads oder Threads?
Nee Threads Bedrohung.
Ja aber man kann es ja auch mit.
Ah es ist Threads. Threads oder Threads. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein schöner Punktenbrecher.
Aber es ist glaub ich hab's versucht mir mal anzuschauen aber im deutschen Appstore
von Apple konnte ich das noch nicht kriegen.
Da gibt's nur irgendeinen Slack Client,
ich sag hier Threads erster Treffer Und da steht dann so not affiliated with
Instagram und wenn du das dann installierst,
Nutzername eingeben, dann gibst du den Nutzernamen ein und dann sagt er,
wir kennen den Nutzernamen nicht, Achtung, das ist nicht das Threads mit Instagram,
die muss halt ihre App updaten, weil sie jetzt auf einmal Millionen Downloads
haben, weil alle den Scheiß buchen und müssen die Leute alle wieder wegschicken.
Oh Gott.
Das halt auch. Aber vielleicht ist das auch geil, nehmen wir das halt.
Läuft's. Nun denn, kommen wir zu unserer tollen Innenministerin.
Die ist ja auch echt on a roll. Erinnerst du dich noch an die Sendung,
die wir gemacht haben, als die neue Regierung so antrat?
Da hatten wir Hoffnung.
Also speziell bei ihr, ich muss das jetzt zugeben. Hatten wir.
Hatten wir. Ja, weil sie ja so sagen wir mal als eine Person ins Innenministerium
kam, die sich zumindest auf Landesebene vorher politisch immer sehr klar gegen
rechts positioniert hat und so ein bisschen den Eindruck machte,
als hätte sie irgendwie Haltung.
Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger geworden in der Zwischenzeit.
Jetzt hat sie dieses ganze Dilemma mit dem geschafften BSI-Präsidenten an der Backe.
Wir erinnern uns, also irgendwie im Fernsehen wurde gesagt der Russe kommt und
dann hat sie dann irgendwie versucht diesen BSI Präsidenten loszuwerden,
weil der mal auf einer Party war und...
Am Ende stellt sich raus, dass an diesen ganzen Vorwürfen relativ wenig dran ist,
aber der Chef musste gehen und damit er überhaupt gehen kann,
weil sie ja so richtig die Kompetenz eigentlich gar nicht hatte,
musste für irgendein Langweileramt im bundesdeutschen Behördenkanon eine neue
Stelle geschaffen werden bzw.
Eine neue Bezahlung für eine existierende Stelle und jemand anders noch in Rente
geschickt werden, Damit Herr Schönenbohm zu gleichen Konditionen weiterarbeiten
kann, weil ihr fehlte halt das Schwert, um ihre schlechten Entscheidungen durchzufechten.
Und damit das zukünftig besser geht, ändert sich jetzt die Regel und macht es
so, dass der BSI Präsident oder die Präsidentin, die wir ja derzeit haben,
auch einfach gefeuert werden kann vom Innenministerium.
Was natürlich total super ist in
dem ganzen Projekt, wir machen das BSI unabhängiger vom Innenministerium.
Ja das ist wirklich, das ist auch interessant, am 15.
Juni ging das unaufgeregt durch den Bundestag,
haben so ein bisschen was geändert, und jetzt wird eben die Leitung des BSI
zu einem außertariflichen Vertragsverhältnis, damit eben kein Beamtenverhältnis
und dann kannst du jetzt super einfach kicken.
Ja, kann im Prinzip auf dem Schleudersitz sitzen und danach werden die Leitungspersonen
des BSI sogenannte politische Beamtinnen sein und damit, ja,
können die dann auch damit rechnen, dass da regelmäßig der eiserne Besen kommt.
Toll, toll Ampel, danke Ampel.
Naja, es läuft irgendwie echt alles nicht besonders rund, aber naja.
Tja.
Das tat es vorher auch nicht.
Ne, ich hatte heute nur so eine schöne, die stellen sich halt bei vielen Dingen
doof an, zum Beispiel bei der Besetzung des Innenministeriums.
Ich hege ja trotzdem noch zu einigen der Ampelpolitiker durchaus eine persönliche Sympathie so,
aber man muss schon sagen,
dass das natürlich, also zum Beispiel tut mir echt leid,
dass die da mit, stell dir mal vor,
du bist Politiker oder Politikerin, da machst du irgendwie so,
Jahrelang sitzt
du in irgendwelchen scheiß Versammlungen und Bierzelten und Oppositionen und
dann wirst du endlich Minister und dann ist irgendwie Christian Lindner auch da.
Das ist schon hart, oder Nancy Faeser wird auf einmal Innenministerin neben
dir, das Das ist auch nicht,
einfach.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht einfach, muss ich wirklich sagen. So,
damit hätten wir noch einen Job.
Wir haben ja, wir werben immer für Jobs. Irgendwann werbe ich ja auch mal für
Jobs, Leute. Ich könnte schon mal kündigen, in drei Monaten gibt es von mir
einen neuen Job. Nein, doch, vielleicht. Also der Netzpolitik.org,
die Redaktion, da hat Anna Biselli mich auch nochmal extra drauf hingewiesen,
die ist ja die Chefredakteurin da. Ich hab ja bei Netzpolitik.org habe ich,
sag ich mal, Connections nach ganz oben. Nach ganz oben.
Echt? Kennst du den Chef oder was?
Ich kenne den Herausgeber, ich kenne die Chefredakteurin,
ihren Kollegen kenne ich noch nicht so gut,
den habe ich aber auch schon öfter mal gesehen, aber ich sag mal,
ganz nach oben habe ich da die Kontakte und die haben, die suchen einen Bufdi.
Ist das sowas wie Mufti?
Nee, Bundesfreiwilligendienst.
Oh, so nennt man das?
Bufdi, ja, das finde ich eigentlich ganz… Ist das das, was man früher Zibi nannte?
Ja, nur dass Zibi nicht wirklich freiwillig da ist und dafür steht halt das F in Bufdi.
Verstehe. Bufdi. By ordre du Bufdi.
Ja, Bufdi klingt wie so ein… Die Ordre des Bufdi.
So, jetzt haben sie, also die haben,
es gibt Rahmenbedingungen für den Freiwilligendienst, das beginnt am 1.
September, dann bist du zwölf Monate da mit 35 Stunden Arbeitszeit und dein
Einsatzplatz ist die Unterstützung in den Bereichen Redaktion, Kreation und Event.
Also erlernen von Recherchen und journalistischem Schreiben,
Hilfe bei Recherchen verfassen von Meldungen, Mitwirkungen am Monitoring der
Nachrichtenlage, Datenbankpflege, Bebilderung von Artikeln unter anderem Mithilfe
von generativer KI wie zum Beispiel mit Journey.
Erstellen von Sharepics, Mithilfe bei Spendenkampagnen, Social Media Accounts
bespielen, Kommunikation mit unserer Community, Unterstützung bei der Organisation
und Durchführung einer Konferenz im Sommer 2024.
Uiuiui. So, da, glaube ich, gibt es einen bunten Strauß.
Und da kann man sich anmelden. Jetzt ist das so.
30 Bildungstage, 30 Urlaubstage, 420 Euro Taschengeld pro Monat.
Das ist wirklich wie Zivildienst. Ich glaube ich habe beim Zivildienst ein bisschen
mehr bekommen, aber ich hatte irgendwas gemacht, warum man mehr bekam.
Irgendeine Zulage oder sowas. Ich war Rettungssanitäter, aber ich weiß nicht,
vielleicht weil ich zuhause gewohnt habe und nicht auf der Stube oder so.
Irgendeine Zulage hatte ich.
Ja, also wenn ihr, und das richtet sich ja im weitesten Sinne an Menschen,
die aus der Schule kommend noch nicht bereit sind,
sich direkt der Ödnis des Studiums oder der, wie nennt man das,
der Erniedrigung der Ausbildung auszuliefern.
Sondern eine Erfahrung in einem Bereich sammeln wollen.
Und ich kann nur sagen, um das, was hier gezahlt wird, mal positiv dastehen
zu lassen, als ich mein Praktikum bei Netzpolitik.org gemacht habe,
habe ich keine 420 Euro bekommen.
Und ja, das war tatsächlich eine der ersten Dinge, die ich nach dem Studium
gemacht habe, mein Praktikum bei Netzpolitik.org,
aus dem dann nachher eine Festanstellung wurde und dann bin ich da ja irgendwann
weggegangen um in der IT-Security.
Zur arbeit ich dachte wollte jetzt sagen dass du danach bist du dann die mittebene
befördert worden das war nämlich auch eine folge davon von dir krieg kein taschengeld, was?
Quatsch. Urlaubstage, Bildungstage, Taschengeld, das kannst du alles vergessen.
Hier kriegt man handfeste, Kohle.
Also ist alles nicht so schlecht gelaufen, sagen wir es mal so.
Nein, absolut nicht. Man muss natürlich schauen, also diese Position richtet
sich ja hier an ganz spezifische Leute.
Da wird jetzt sicherlich niemand seine Redakteursposten beim Spiegel Verlag
verkündigen, sondern das ist hier eben ein Bufdi, der hier gesucht wird.
Der oder die hier sicherlich in einer coolen Redaktion eine ganze Menge Dinge
lernen kann, die natürlich dann auch einen Fuß in der Tür hat,
übernommen zu werden und so weiter.
Insgesamt das Team, was Netzpolitik.org hat, umfasst aktuell 19 Mitarbeiterinnen,
zwei Praktikantinnen und eine freiwillige Person.
Das ist wahrscheinlich dann Bufdi, ne? Bufdi ist auch.
Also ich würde halt sagen, ich mach's, aber wenn ihr Bufdi zu mir sagt,
dann regnet das Ohrfeigen hier.
Ja genau, aber da kann man sich bewerben und ich glaube,
wenn man sich für Bufdi interessiert, ich meine die Alternative,
das muss man auch sagen, gibt es sicherlich eine Reihe schlechterer Alternativen für Bufdis. A.
Das ist so.
Was ich übrigens sehr schön finde ist, dieses Jobposting ist dann eben auch
unter fjbeteiligung.de,
also das ist irgendwie offenbar dieses Freiwilligendienstportal,
wo dann alle diese Angebote sind und da haben sie als Abbildung,
das sollte man vielleicht fairerweise sagen, das Foto da, das ist die Volksbühne.
Da hängt dann so, das ist Netzpolitik dran, fight for your digital rights,
als sie halt mal ihre Das-ist-Netz-Politik-Konferenz in der Volksbühne hatten.
Ich kann sagen, das wird jetzt nicht direkt der Arbeitsort sein,
der sieht ganz schön aus, aber der Arbeitsort von Netzpolitik.org,
das Büro ist ja in der Schönhauser Allee, ist auch nicht unattraktiv gelegen.
Und auch nicht weit weg. Also wenn euch die Wiese vor der Volksbühne gefällt,
dann könnt ihr da durchaus in der Pause mal hingehen, aber euer Büro wird jetzt
nicht hinter diesen sechs Säulen in der großen Glasfront sein.
Dafür habt ihr einen Fahrstuhl.
Aber könnte, könnte trotzdem nett werden. Na gut.
Das könnte nett werden. So.
Klingt echt ein bisschen komisch, ne?
Die meisten Abkürzungen in Deutschland klingen ein bisschen komisch.
Also ist der angesächsische Sprachraum oft etwas kreativer, was so Benennungen
betrifft. Aber das ist, ja man auf hohem Niveau.
Dafür haben wir ja eine, eine Gesellschaft, Eine Gesellschaft,
die nicht in die Zukunft fühlen kann und auch ansonsten schwer zu überzeugen
ist, das Richtige zu tun.
Schön ist, aber soviel könnte ich auch noch sagen, also bei Netzpolitik.org
vor der Tür gibt es keine Parkplätze, da kann man mit dem Fahrrad gut hinfahren
und mit der U-Bahn des Rosa-Luxemburg-Platzes ist das, glaube ich, die Urnenstadt.
Echt keine, kein Parkplatz.
Hinten in den Höfen, das ist ja ein zweiter Hinterhof, da könnte...
Sind hier etwa alle für Fahrradparkplätze weggefallen?
Ja, ja, also sag mal so, vielleicht gibt's da, es kann sogar sein,
dass da hinten auf dem Hof auch Parkplätze sind, aber ich vermute,
da müsste man dann nochmal mit der Hausverwaltung reden,
was sie denn so für einen eingezäunten Parkplatz in Berlin-Mitte am Rosa-Luxemburg-Platz nehmen.
Könnt ihr mir vorstellen, dass dann größere Teile eures Puff-die-Taschen-Geldes
dann leider drauf geht, für das Parken eures Mercedes?
Komm, lass uns Schluss machen. Das war's mit dieser Woche.
Wir werden auch weiter versuchen, euch regelmäßig hier zu informieren.
Letzte Woche hat es leider nicht geklappt. Jetzt kommt dieser Sommer.
Ihr wisst schon, es wird ein bisschen kritisch.
Von daher könnte es sein, dass es etwas eingeschränkte Versorgung gibt. Aber?
Nächste Woche haben wir auf jeden Fall schon mal einen Sendungstermin.
Und ich glaube im Juli zumindest von meiner Seite geben sich da noch Möglichkeiten.
Und ich kann ja jetzt auch schon bekannt geben, dass wir die Nachricht erhalten haben,
dass unsere Einreichung zum Camp 2023, zum Chaos Communication Camp,
wo jetzt alle Tickets ausverkauft sind, die wurde angenommen.
Insofern wird es ein Logbuch live geben in Mildenberg, irgendwann zwischen dem 15. und 19. August.
Das sah auch schon mal. Ja alle Tickets ausverkauft.
Naja es gab drei Vorverkaufstermine ich glaube nicht, dass ich wenn ich jetzt
auf tickets-events.ccc.de gehe, dass ich da jetzt noch irgendwie ein Camp Ticket
kriege oder das würde also ich gehe jetzt einfach mal davon aus es waren alle.
Nicht verfügbar nicht verfügbar nicht verfügbar nicht verfügbar nicht verfügbar
nicht verfügbar nicht verfügbar nicht verfügbar ja.
Aber ich stelle immer mal wieder fest, dass Leute nach Tickets fragen oder Tickets anbieten.
Insofern ist man da, glaube ich, ganz gut beraten, noch so in den Mastodon-Threads
zu bleiben. Und derartiges.
Ja da wird sich auf jeden Fall noch das eine oder andere ergeben,
weil Leute dann auch mal wieder mal absagen.
Also wenn ihr aufs Camp wollt, dann gebt nicht gleich auf.
Wenn ihr Camper-Tickets habt, dann könnt ihr gerne eine Mail schreiben.
Die bitte nicht öffentlich anbieten, die alle direkt zu uns. Okay?
Genau, die alle zu uns.
Wir verkaufen die dann meistens. Ne, tatsächlich, noch kein sicher.
Bin da in Mastodon-Verhandlungen und hoffe, dass ich nicht einem nigerianischen
Prinzen zum Opfer falle.
Das wird sich dann zeigen. Das berichte ich dir nächste Woche.
Überweis mal Bitcoin.
So Leute, wir sagen tschüss, bis bald. Bis bald. Tschau tschau.